[Music]
[Music]
valuetainment giving
[Music]
[Music]
well uh folks today is a special podcast
uh it's one we've been waiting for the
the the person that's on today dr ben
carson
you've you've seen him many different
places but you know for most people that
maybe maybe you don't know what he's
done in the past i wrote a book about 12
years ago called doing the impossible
this man actually did the impossible and
they made a movie after him
uh he successfully separated conjoined
twins which was a 22-hour surgery on uh
with a team of 70 people people said
that will never happen it's not possible
he was able to do that later on a movie
came out gifted hand starring cuba
gooden jr
and then he later became the a
presidential candidate running against
many different heavyweights
and then became the secretary of housing
and urban development under president
donald trump and today
when he speaks people listen dr ben
carson thank you so much for being a
guest on that well thanks for having me
i enjoy being here yes you know i read
your book the moment it came out of one
of the books america the beautiful yes
i picked it up
and i read it i said you know the the
example i think uh uh one of our guys
here sam just came and spoke to you was
telling me how he was speaking to you
when he was in colombia his mother made
him watch your movie and read your book
gifted hands and he says she said to him
now you know why i'm tough on you guys
you're going to thank me later because
look how dr ben carson thanked his mom
because i think you guys were required
to read two books a week and write a
report at the end of the week and if i'm
not mistaken your mom wasn't able to
read or something that's right she was
illiterate but
she made us read our friends her friends
all criticized her they said you can't
make boys stay in the house reading
books they'll grow up and they'll hate
you
and i used to overhear them and i would
say you know they're right mother
[Laughter]
and we still had to do it
but she had the last laugh because one
son became a brain surgeon the other
became a rocket scientist are you
kidding me see i didn't know about it
but the other son became a rocket
scientist i mean that was 10 years ago
when i read it
he's
powerful story so you know we do a
similar thing with our kids but you know
yesterday my son sat and finished a 300
page book on his own yes yeah tico and
you they couldn't distract them our
required reading is 20 pages a day from
the moment you turn six years old you're
supposed to read 20 pages every day
including sunday saturdays all that
that's gonna pay off and and the only
currency in our house where you get to
ask and negotiate with things is books
you read books you get to negotiate you
don't read books you don't have leverage
to negotiate but now
the teacher calls me telling me you have
to tell your oldest son to stop reading
because he's not paying attention in
class i said man with all due respect
that is one thing i'm not going to be
doing this kid can read all he wants and
you just got to get his attention maybe
you got to do a better job selling them
on paying attention to you but this
kid's going to keep reading anyways it's
great to have you on uh in a very uh
special week that you came here i don't
know if you guys heard or not
uh abraham linc i'd like to talk to you
about abraham lincoln's a great
granddaughter that lost in wyoming this
week uh i don't know if you know what
her name is liz cheney uh is she she
lost did you see that she well i saw she
lost she lost yeah and she uh she's uh
comparing herself to lincoln i'd love to
get your feedback on that legendary
moment special moment you know what
happened to her uh cdc came up with some
changes and guidelines apparently they
hired a new person talking about the
fact that you know some of the things we
did was wrong i'm sure you read the
report that we didn't do this right we
didn't do that right but one of the
things that they said they didn't do
right was kind of uncomfortable for me
they said we should have mandated states
to send out this instead of making it
more volunteer so i kind of want to get
your feedback on that okay and then
obviously with what we have going on
with the inflation reduction
uh act uh into law um uh you know irs
whistleblower coming out 87 000 new irs
agents is that a good thing is that a
bad thing fbi you know raiding president
trump's house we got to talk about that
uh we have uh a uh uh story by the daily
beast talking about viper merrick
garland's trump fbi rate is only in the
first inning meaning he's got more to
show for uh kirsten or what you have to
say about that
and then a few uh ideas with nba this
week coming out dwyane wade claims
the the hatred of miami heat's big three
uh when they were winning championships
is because they were black men right
which which uh you know
i'm really curious what you'll say about
that part they're taking election day
off we've got a bunch of other things
that's going on bloomberg wrote an
article expose on bill gates which is
kind of weird for bloomberg to write an
exposure on bill gates when bloomberg
writes an explosion on bill gates you
have to
you know know that there's credibility
there behind her
elon musk was at kevin mccarthy's gop
retreat in wyoming very very weird
people showing up to weird parties
and then a couple other things we'll
talk about that has to do with joe rogan
the heated debate over you know
roe v wade that he had recently but
aside from that just an open-ended
question for you
so you know
the day comes where we find out
president biden is going to be our
president okay
and it was official it was no longer
waiting the inauguration took place
president trump didn't show up
everybody's sitting there saying okay
this is our guy this is who we have to
run with this is who's representing the
free world today he's our
commander-in-chief
fast forward from that day to today is
today exactly what you expected it to be
is it better is it worse or is it
exactly what you thought it was going to
be well i didn't have a lot of the
expectations for
uh our current president
because
you know he basically
didn't show up during the primary
process and during the whole
presidential campaign
and when he did show up
it wasn't particularly impressive
but i knew that there were a lot of
other people who were
pulling the strings
and i have a reasonable idea of who
those people are
so i expected
a very leftward tilt
and that's exactly what has happened
when you say you have an idea of who
those people
reasonable idea about who those people
are
does the rest of america who votes also
know who those people are or is it
something that only some of the people
on the inside know who those people are
i think a lot of people who've been
paying attention to
the general tenor
of the country over the last
couple of decades
have a pretty good idea of who those
people are are you able to talk about it
or is it like this you know illuminati
secret type of freemason stuff that we
want to get out of yale well let me just
say that there are people who have been
involved previously with trying to
fundamentally change your country
internally right
so it's okay so
you know what are you talking about
globalists some folks that are maybe i
think they're associated with some of
the globalists okay so why why would
they let's let's go there why would they
want to do that why would they want to
fundamentally change
uh the one country
that the world uses
the five letter word dream with you know
we don't use the dream word with any
country the only one we've ever used it
with was america the american dream why
are they trying to change it well
remember there have been people who have
uh disputed the legitimacy of our
governmental system since the very
beginning
they said you can't have a country
that's run on the will of the people
you have to have a monarch
you have to have a ruling body
and
those kinds of ideals have been around
from the very beginning and they're
still there
and there are those who believe that the
ruling class knows better than the
people
and
it's really for the good of the people
that you empower those people and that
they need to do whatever they have to do
in order to gain the power
in order to do quote good for the people
unquote yeah but when you're saying the
monarch but aren't those guys from the
outside
so the argument is there's no way
america can make it without us we're a
monarch right they desperately need us
versus in this case you're saying last
20 years these are people on the inside
why are people on the inside
trying to break apart the one idea that
turned into what this experiment that
turned into what it is today power
they want power they want control it's a
natural tendency
it's a human tendency to want to control
everybody to want to control your
environment
and that's why if you go back through
history and you look at various
societies
there is no period of time where people
can just live in peace where they can
just live and let live
no
no i got to control you i got to take
your stuff i got to be in
and in control of it we're all like that
we're like that but that is the very
reason that the founders of our country
worked so hard
on our constitution because they knew
there was a natural tendency to want to
control a natural tendency for
government to want to grow to infiltrate
and to control
and it was to give the people a tool
which would allow us to remain free
it is being challenged probably to the
severest degree right now so were they
also driven by power
the founders
uh they were different
tell me tell me in what way
because they actually people like george
washington
declined
to be made a monarch people wanted him
to be the monarch he said no
that's not the system that we have this
is about the people
and the freedom of the people and you
look at uh you know john adams
and
you know he said
our constitution was designed for a
moral
and religious people and is wholly
inadequate for the governance of any
other
you had you look at some of the writings
of people like thomas jefferson
who realized how important it was
for people to maintain freedom
and even though he had slaves
and several of the founders had several
didn't but several did
most of them
ended up freeing their slaves
and
i think
realizing the internal conflict
when you're saying that all men are
created equal
but then you have slaves
but
you know those who hate the united
states have tried to make slavery
a unique issue for us and i say we are
particularly evil because we had slavery
but if you know anything about
world history you know that virtually
every society has adults with slavery
and that there are more slaves in the
world today than there have ever been at
any point in time when you look at human
trafficking and the number one consumer
of it the united states of america so do
we still have some issues absolutely
there's no question about it but we're
not unique because because of slavery we
are unique only in the sense
that we had so many people who were
vehemently opposed to slavery that we
fought a bloody civil war to get rid of
it
and that's really what we need to teach
our children we need to teach them that
during slavery there were a lot of
people from all kinds of backgrounds
who you know established the underground
railroad who did all kinds of things to
try to undermine
that concept
of human bondage
so so you you said something when i
asked you the question about when
president biden
you know the inauguration did you expect
it to be what it is today
and you said you had an idea because of
who was behind it and i said are these
people that the public knows about and
you said they have a general sense then
i ask you why would they want to do it
this was been going on for about 20
years is this specifically a 20-year
thing or is this a thing and then you
said it's been going on for a while
because if you go back 20 years
president was president bush so you know
junior are you so this is not a 20-year
thing this has been going on for a while
that's been going on for very long
internally yes i know milton friedman
once said you know the only marxists
that are left in the world are the ones
in college universities in the us well
think about this uh in the late 50s
nikita khrushchev
said to the white eisenhower
your grandchildren's children will live
under communism and we won't have to
fire a shot
so
what did he know
he knew what some of the things that
were going on already he knew about the
plan
to gain control of the media and the
schools
and to replace
faith in god with faith in government
and to
raise the national debt to astronomical
levels so that you could justify other
things he knew all of that was going to
occur
and how successful it would be and it is
successful so
i'm sorry go ahead
it's successful
and that's why we need to stop it
if if we really want our children and
our grandchildren to live in freedom
the kind of freedom that we had growing
up
we have to stand up we can't simply
allow
this to continue
dr carson for me you know one may say
uh uh fear is a great motivator right
fear sharpens listening when people are
afraid they listen when people are not
afraid they don't listen this is valid
in voting in marketing and sales
and pandemic in pandemics and anything
right so
but somebody from the left may say well
the right is selling fear that the
communists are trying to take over
america okay then the left the right may
sell
that the left is trying to control
america and you got to be very careful
because of you know what they're doing
you know they're they want to control
you
so which fear
should we be buying you know because
left says the right is trying to go back
and take away all your freedoms and you
know take away women's rights and they
want to go back to what it was back in
the days and they may even take this
away from you and take that away from
you
both sides are selling the fear how does
the voter
sit there and say which fear is accurate
could they both be real is one fake who
do i trust
i would say trust your eyes and trust
your ears
and trust your heart
you know open your eyes and see what's
going on
um
does it appear that people are trying to
induction at our kids
what do you think
when uh they're telling
little boys and little girls you might
not be a little boy or a little girl
what are they trying to do when they're
telling kids that the most important
determinant
in your life is the color of your skin
when they're telling white kids that you
and your
ancestors are oppressors and are
responsible for others telling black
kids and minorities
that you
are victims
and you'll never be able to achieve
because of the way that this system is
set up
does that sound like indoctrination or
just benign chatter i don't think so
open your eyes and open your ears when
you know you're telling
and confusing children
childhood is supposed to be a time of
joy
and learning
and you're taking little kids and saying
do you think you're really a girl
are you you think you're really a boy
now children are naturally curious
and children are suggestible
so
you know
it's sort of like taking a
kindergartener
and trying to teach them calculus
they're not ready for that they're not
even close to ready for that that's very
abusive
or do you think maybe it's okay
you know open your eyes and open your
ears
and listen to your heart
you know that's not right
you know how hard it is uh
to do that because
when you open your eyes and you open
your ears ninety percent of the
messaging is coming from one place so if
i only take the council of open my eyes
and open my ears i'm only hearing one
side of the argument ninety percent of
time and that's why i said also listen
to your heart
people there are things that people for
instance
we know what a woman is
let's not
let people confuse us about
we've known for
ever
since we've known about genetics
xx
woman
xy
man
in the story
but can you confuse people about it
absolutely
how effective is gaslighting and the
usage of disinformation you know how how
effective is that i know
you know we've heard the kgb member from
the past when that one interview the way
they're going to do it is you know the
usage of disinformation but how
effective is that model well look how
effective it was
in germany
you know
think back to the
30s
and the 40s
and you just take a lie and you continue
to repeat it
put it into various forms
and pretty soon
people begin to believe that it's true
i can't
believe that most of the people
in germany actually
grew up believing that stuff
but hearing it all the time
having it foisted on you from several
different directions
and you start to say
okay yeah maybe okay so then then then
the counsel
of open your eyes open your ears
and
you know open your heart
yet you're being fed so much
disinformation and gaslighting
to the point where it's easy to get
people to eventually second-guess
themselves i mean what's the art of war
the art of
competition you know boxing half the
battle is convincing the other guy that
he's not as good as you have to battle
is getting the other person
to you know and if if the majority of
the populace is naive that is a very
effective strategy so to only say
listen you know see and heart is that
enough
well you have to spend a little bit of
time listening to a lot of different
things you can't just listen to one
source
you can't just listen to
you know nbc
or fox
or cnn
uh you have to vary what you're
listening to and you have to be willing
to have open conversations with people
it makes a big difference
and you know i grew
i grew up in detroit
you know a very
liberal left-wing place
and in boston
a very liberal left-wing place
and then went off to college in new
haven
a very liberal left-wing place and then
went to medical school in ann arbor a
very liberal left wing
and then came and did my internship in
residency in baltimore a very liberal
lovely so guess what i was a liberal
left-winger
and then uh one day i did something that
liberals aren't supposed to do
i listened
to a conservative
that was ronald reagan
and i said this guy sounds just like my
mother
he says the same things that she says
what were the types of things he was
saying that resonated with you this
isn't i assume 1980 or 79
that
the person who's most responsible for
what happens to you is you
uh
not someone else
personal responsibility personal
responsibility is very big and
at the same time as a young attending
neurosurgeon i was seeing
so many
patients
and people
who were dependent on the government
who were healthy able-bodied people
and
i said this is absolutely wrong these
people could be successful
and doing well in our society
and they're
dependent and they've become victims
and i determined at that point that
you know not only would i be a physician
but i was i was going to work toward
helping people get out of poverty
while you're looking at these guys
that's what you're thinking to yourself
i'm gonna help these guys get out of
poverty yeah
got it okay so uh listen
watch see
heart
consume content from the other side
uh don't just listen to content from
your own side be open to other ideas and
be willing to talk
you know
communication is so vitally important
have you noticed that on these
radical left-wing college campuses
they don't
want to have a conversation with the
other side they don't want students
exposed to the other side have you
noticed that they're doing a lot of
kicking out people they don't agree with
right exactly
and
you know when people get married before
they get married you know they can't
keep their hands off each other they
just love and when they're away from
each other on a telephone talk
before they get divorced they stop
talking the next thing you know their
spouse is the devil incarnate that's
what happens
and that's what's happening to our
country right now with the polarization
everybody getting in their respective
corners and hurling hand grenades at
each other rather than having open
discussion i think you would find
that the most radical left-winger and
the most radical right-winger agree on
90 of stuff is that ten percent
that the media takes and they stir it up
and they magnify it and they try to make
each ot each people people hate each
other
uh people who live peacefully together
for the last 20 years
all of a sudden now they hate each other
because they have different yard signs i
mean
we
the american people can't allow this to
happen because they know
that the only way to destroy this
country is from the inside
you said talking yesterday i saw an
article from is it axios or who's the
axios and i saw this article about the
fact that many leaders are afraid to
share their opinions today publicly
ceos executive did you see that article
ceos executives it's like listen i'm
better off just not saying anything even
though i agree with them if you look at
this post tyler if we can put this up
difference between being public and
private opinions right so you look at
right there this is from june 8th it's a
survey of 3334 american adults conducted
may 23rd to june 8.
ceos should take a stand on
controversial social issues 14 privately
agree 28 publicly agree
public schools focus too much on racism
in the us 33 percent privately agree
43 percent publicly agree this used to
be a bigger percentage where we publicly
agreed
mask wearing was effective to stop cover
19. 47 percent publicly agree
59 pri i'm sorry 47 privately 59
publicly discussing gender identity in
public schools is inappropriate for k3
children
50 53
privately agree
63 publicly agree abortion should be
left up to a woman and her doctor 58 67
and and when you go down and look at
this
one of the things that we become because
when i got into business one of my
mentors gave me some advice he said look
there's three things you should never
talk about
with people don't talk politics don't
talk religion and don't talk personal
live sex things like that i'm like okay
and guess what we like to talk about
i like to debate god i like to debate
politics and i like to debate marriage
relationship sex all that stuff because
it's a big part of our lives but it's a
form of silencing so how much risk do
leaders have today
for because by the way but i i sat down
with a youtuber last week four million
subscribers player in the marketplace
and one of the questions he asks is
when did you get comfortable talking
about politics
and i said just so you know i know what
you're thinking because in the youtube
world
you know when they see somebody talking
about issues that really matter they're
like oh that guy's about to lose
everything he's got because you're not
supposed to talk about it he had such a
big brand with business and
entrepreneurship look he's about to lose
it because he's touching these subjects
he's going to lose an audience all this
other stuff okay the alternative to me
of being silenced i just can't live with
that i live like that for 10 years in
iran it's not part of my dna to do that
it's the reason why we're in america
it's the reason why i started a business
it's the reason why i'm a capitalist
right
why do you think so many leaders
today are afraid to publicly discuss
important issues
that both themselves their families are
being impacted and the people at their
workplace well because there are
consequences for it there's no question
about that but
remember
as our national anthem says in the end
of the first answer
the home of the brave
the land of the land of the free
you can't be the land of the free if
you're not the home of the prey
so unless you're actually willing to
stand up for what you believe in
uh your freedom is going to be gradually
eroded and that's been the history of
societies throughout the history of the
world
the united states
has been different up until now
and i say this is probably the most
extreme challenge
to who we are
that we have ever had
right now
and uh we're on the precipice of
deciding which way we're going to go
are we going to be like
everybody else
or is this truly going to be the shiny
city on the hill
that represents freedom and justice
can i follow up on that with you and
this is an article that i think we can
even reference and then there's a
question at the end it says
self-silencing that's the terminology
that axios is using
is people saying what they think others
want to hear rather than what they
actually truly feel right and it's
skewing our understanding of how
americans really feel about abortion
covid
um what children are taught in school
and other hot button issues and then it
goes on to say why it matters this is
the best predictor of private behavior
and private opinion now obviously this
is we're talking about current times but
i remember
first seeing you
uh when it you know in the mainstream
media at the national prayer breakfast
this is under the obama tenure uh i
don't know what year it was exactly but
you 2013 2013 okay
and you
uh
two seats away from i mean you're
standing at the podium obama's there
michelle about i think jeff sessions was
the one next to you so um and he was
this is before the jeff sessions trump
you know that whole thing
but you received national headlines for
essentially
calling out obama indirectly but
standing right there talking about this
exact same topic right here so has it
gotten worse since obama like what's
what's changed how much worse is it now
well uh
during that speech
you know i talked about political
correctness right and
how it was antithetical to the
principles of freedom
and
that if it continued to grow it would be
a major blow to our country
and it has continued to grow and it is a
major blow it has morphed into
and
you know it is
is a real problem because the rest of
the world looks to this country
for freedom
for examples and for leadership
and if we go down
believe me the rest of the world goes
down too
what was the world like before america
became the great power think about it
you had all these despots going around
crushing anybody who was weaker than
they were pre-world war two you're
referring to
that subsided to a large degree as our
power increased
but as we
are becoming less powerful and less
respected
those despots are starting to rise up
again
do you have a follow-up no i will
to your point you're saying the despots
are trying to are
starting to rise up again
currently or how long has that been
going on uh
for the last couple of years
you see putin
you see uh
you know china you see
north korea starting to kick up its
hills
and these are things to be expected when
you don't have
a powerful
example
like the united states that will stand
for principle but if you're saying the
last x amount of years you're talking
the bush years you're talking obama
years you're talking trump and now biden
so there's two democrats two republicans
so
have you seen a change under different
presidential it's gotten worse under the
current administration
i mean starting with the debacle and
afghanistan
i mean
that
was like taking a loud speaker and
announcing to the world we have no idea
what we're doing
there's a lot of people who say it was
time to get the hell out of afghanistan
though it was time to get out but you
have to get out in an order
you don't leave 80 billion dollars worth
of high-tech equipment there and
take out your military force before you
take out the people they're protecting i
mean
a third grader would know that
but as far as despots go um you know
obama received a lot of heat for his
sort of
apology tour around the middle east
right whatever he's doing in iran and
around nuclear deal and and the other
and then trump received a lot of heat
for cozying up the dictators whether you
want to call it putin or kim jong-un or
um
the gentleman in the philippines i
forget his name
um
anyone got his name yeah whatever
you know uh durant whatever his name is
but he received a lot of uh whether it's
m what is it dude duterte duterte
duterte exactly or mbs from saudi arabia
so is there enough blame to go around
for both sides
there's plenty of blame to go around
but it seems to be accelerating now
in the last 18 months our weakness seems
to be
much more manifest
in the last 18 months or so
and when people don't believe that you
have power
they take advantage of you
and you know look at what we're doing
with our trading policies with china
i mean right now their economy is quite
weak
uh they've got some significant issues
going on this would be the appropriate
time to begin to apply some pressure
to get them to
start acting in a way that's
more reasonable and fair to everybody
else not just to their advantage what do
you think the current regime could be
doing because correct me if i'm wrong i
don't know if biden changed his stance
on what trump was doing with all the
tariffs and everything that was going on
and obviously he's not as vocal about
china well he's he has removed many of
the tariffs
he's made it much easier
for china
to trade we should not be making it
easier we should be making it more
difficult and we should be pressuring
them
you know not to
encourage slave labor with the uyghurs
and
uh
you know
basically when we see people
with policies that oppose
the kinds of things that our country has
stood for
we shouldn't be getting in bed with them
i got a question for you so the other
day and i i don't know why i asked this
in the last few weeks the other day my
kids and i were watching pearl harbor
and the story with ben affleck and the
other actor and you know this whole love
story and they go to war and what the
reason was my son asks so why why did
japan attack us
what was that all about
and you know the story is about oil and
negotiation and increasing you know
putting 94 percent of money in u.s on
hold and they couldn't touch it and
terrorists and all this other stuff so
that was japan's way of retaliating to
say hey we're all so strong here and
then
you know fdr comes back years later i
think five years later truman drops the
nuclear bomb and you know hiroshima we
know the story right okay
so
so then uh
these boys are eight and ten years old
they said so daddy did we do the right
thing dropping uh you know the nuclear
bomb
then my other son asks do we do the
right thing
you know
holding on to their money and taxing
them for the oil and the way we
negotiate it
and then did they do the right thing
attacking us first
should we have not done anything and you
know because i said when a nuclear bomb
dropped it cost this many people's lives
and it did this and it did that and when
they attacked us three thousand wounded
so the three thousand soldiers died
three to four thousand all these people
were wounded we lost all this equipment
you know could this have been prevented
right okay
so then bring that to today
some may say when i have late night
debates with guys that are comfortable
talking that are not willing to talk on
camera there's a different conversation
that on camera everybody wants to talk
well i don't really want to touch
politics privately that's all i want to
talk about with a cigar
some may say well you know
trump's method of having strong tariffs
on china
and putting a chokehold on them is the
reason why we got a bio warfare and
kovitt came out and they did this and
look what happened to america
and because he was strong-arming them so
much that they had to respond and the
way they responded they did it in a way
that they blamed somebody else and
didn't take the responsibility and they
cost the world trillions of dollars but
they got away with murder and guess what
they got the guy out of the house
you know and he's no longer running
white house so china essentially won
because trump was over negotiating with
china so now that's them my question to
you
when it comes down to foreign affairs
people on the right will say
look you want to talk about issues
nobody talked about isis under trump
everybody thought world war iii was
going to get started it didn't palestine
and israel you know stuff that had never
happened before you know meeting with
this person meeting with that person
russia was leaving you know ukraine
alone china wasn't doing anything with
taiwan and then
when you say that argument then the left
people on the other side will say well
yeah if it wasn't for him we would have
coveted because he pushed china so hard
what's your argument when it comes down
to foreign relations that 90 of the
issues the the world really is not aware
of it's privately that's been negotiated
amongst the people of power do you think
a bit of the strong armament that trump
had is what caused china to retaliate in
a way
that is not going to come back to them
and they're never going to be held
accountable for it
i think there's evil in the world
i don't think it's going away anytime
soon
and i think we have to oppose it
and
we have to decide
what is right
and we follow that line
what is moral and what is right
are there going to be consequences no
matter which direction you go
absolutely
because you have good and you have evil
and we have to stay on the side of
what's good
that's the way i look at it
he didn't really answer my question
though
so my question is you're you're a very
smart man you're very uh
um
wise man you know i i think one of the
things we when i watched you when he
gave that speech with the president
obama sitting right there that's the day
when i realized you have some brass you
know you're and i know you're as a
christian man that brass is not in
proverbs or you know ecclesiastes but
in the streets you have brass and you
you stood up and you had guts maybe
another word to use
i said
i like this guy he's tough because some
people when they hear you speak by the
way your tone confuses the audience and
i don't think it necessarily
they think they think i'm soft and weak
because i i don't get excited i i
actually think it doesn't help you in
the marketing side of things
i don't think it helps when because
uh uh
when it comes down to elections and
things like that because you know it's
marketing it's showmanship as all of
that stuff and that's not your style but
if you want to put it together you
showed that day that you could put it
together if you want to put a show on
you don't have a problem doing that but
going back to it
um
you're sharp
you're wise
you're calculating
to have a 70 team man put together where
it's such detail to be able to separate
conjoined twins
the amount of detail that goes in that
in the
percentage of you making a mistake to
costing two people's lives that's going
to be on your hands further that's
that's detail that's methodical that
strategy that's technical that's a lot
of that
how do you personally feel about the
fact that maybe when somebody comes
after us
you know or you know we have certain
relations which we know they've been
making a lot of money off us way more
than we've been making them we turned
them into a superpower not the other way
around without us china is not who they
are today they've been for many years
they've been a superpower but they co
they go up and down quite often because
they like to control and the people
realize it doesn't work they have a fall
then they come back up and they fool the
people and they control again and it
falls it's just a very cyclical cycle
they go through
but at the same time when it comes down
to
you know your president then you're
going with the your number one enemy
there isn't anybody that's close to
china russia is big but not at the level
of china right
um
how should that be handled when it comes
out again
next person gets elected states to santa
states trump said it's michelle obama
whoever it's going to be president again
you're going to face china again no
question and they're going to push the
envelope again should you double down on
tariffs the way we did before was like
add another five percent add another 10
percent add another this
should that be our approach you have to
inflict pain
you have to discourage that kind of
behavior
and that's how you do it
so
there's probably a host of things that
could be done
that they wouldn't particularly like
and i think this is where negotiation
comes in
and you start to say
look this is where we are this is where
you are
uh
let's see if we can work in such a way
that we both benefit
if not
these are the things that we're not
going to be able to
to cooperate with you on
and you might find them rather
distasteful
but this is the reason that we're doing
them
you know it's it's interesting you say
that we talked about this where i said
if we would have gone four more years of
pain like that to china i don't think
they could have handled it i don't think
so either yeah and you know look at
russia
now what did we do with them
we empowered them
we gave them the energy keys
and
do you think
putin would have gone into ukraine if we
had not given him all that power and we
weren't giving him all of this money of
course not
so i mean there are consequences and we
find ourselves in difficult situations
because we do things that don't make
sense
is green energy a good goal to have
renewable energy absolutely
are we ready to switch everything over
to it right now absolutely not
do we have a wealth of
fossil fuels and have we learned how to
extract them in a safe way so that we
have the cleanest air in the cleanest
water since it's been measured
absolutely should we use those things
to get where we want to get with the
renewable energy absolutely
should we just throw them away and
create a giant chasm
and and further the time when we'll be
able to have green energy absolutely not
but that's exactly what we've done and
at the same time empowering putin it
makes
zero sense
when you don't
use your brain
when you just react to things and you
say
because my enemy or my foe
use this i don't want to use it so just
shut down the pipeline shut down all of
this stuff let's put all these
regulations in place
that's kind of the way a three-year-old
thinks
but that's on both sides though dr
carson uh not not not this blatantly
i mean when you do things that hurt the
american people right so that you can
get back
at your political adversary you know
this is this is probably one of the most
blatant examples of that that has ever
occurred is it fair to say that to the
left putin is their number one enemy and
to the right china is the number one
enemy is that a way of putting it would
you
i wouldn't simply you know what i'm
saying but i i think perhaps
uh on their list of priorities that
might be the case right so so the the
left uh democrats don't want to
see russia getting stronger and they see
that as a threat and to the right maybe
it's more china
than it is uh russia i asked that
because when you put terrorists do you
remember the cfo
of huawei where the daughter was in
canada was doing business with iran and
then all of a sudden president trump
said wow you're out and you got to get
out of here and
even though maybe it was good for us to
have a third phone to have a competitor
because in us right now we really don't
have a second competitor on phones true
truthfully nowadays
if a person has a droid
i think you don't fully understand what
a blue text is and how much you're
screwing up group texts when you're when
you're the only person that's green you
know so i think america needed
competition but at the same time if
huawei were using it to get information
out of u.s to
take it back there i think that's also
the right move to make but but what what
what have we done
with respect to china and russia
we have driven them together yeah i
agree and that creates an even bigger
problem no question about that no
question about that
um
i'm sorry go ahead you were saying
something yeah so
uh you know our
our foreign policy
is
not particularly strong right now
because we don't really have a foreign
policy we kind of react
and what we really need to do
and you know democrats and republicans
can sit down together
and openly discuss what are the things
that are beneficial for our country
and for our people
i think that's the reason
that so many people have been attracted
to trump because he puts america first
but you know that does that doesn't need
to be a political issue
of course you take care of your own
people first that's why when you get on
an airplane they make the announcement
in case of an emergency your mask will
drop down put yours on that's right and
then help your neighbor you're not
advocating wearing masks though
okay i mean let's just be clear here
come on now and only in case of
emergency though
indeed yeah but i understand what you're
saying i guess i guess where i'm going
with this is the following
uh
we know
america is not proud of their president
today they don't wake up in the morning
having the poster of their i would have
to say
in the last hundred years
if we had to say which president has the
least amount of posters in offices is
probably joe biden
i don't know if that makes sense or not
like you know how people proudly i saw
people proudly put up
by what do you call it obama on the wall
proudly oh people beyond oh
but people proudly put up trump not a
question but i would say people proudly
put up bush and bush and clinton okay i
i would go into offices to a lesser
extent of trump
no question but even if you go yeah you
know people proudly put up reagan for
sure people can't put up jfk no doubt
i'm telling you the poster business for
joe biden is struggling they're probably
fine you know who disagrees with you who
nobody yeah so nobody's like oh bite and
he's the man i love that guy yeah no i
he's the anti-trump that's why he got
elected right he is the he's the he's
not the best anti-trump but he is the
anti-trump right he's the anti-trump
that he could've had
uh so so for you you know 2016 2015 you
guys went through it you've actually
been through the process and it's not
like you went through the process and
you were like you know yeah you're just
throwing the towel you know throwing
your name you weren't tiptoeing in there
no no no you didn't go in it to
uh hey i'd like on my wikipedia profile
to say former presidential candidate
that wasn't you that's not you you went
in there and
there's a part of me
and i you know
feel free to push back and disagree with
me on this year
there's a part of me that feels like
you know you read the stories of the
kennedy family and you read the stories
of bush family they may politically be
on different ends whatever but as far as
legacy-wise family the kind of a last
thing that they built both of them was
gonna make your money take care of your
family
and then figure out a way to contribute
to society and one of the ways to do it
is through
politics okay go get back you know go
get involved in politics
is it fair to assume that maybe there
was
some plans that every time you were
seeing stuff and tell telling yourself i
think i can do that better i think i can
bring value here
was the decision of running something
that was an aspirational thing that you
thought about
10 20 30 years before you ran or was it
one of those things like you know what i
think i'm gonna run right now
no it was uh it was after the
prayer breakfast in 2013
uh and all of a sudden everybody was
saying you should run for president
which i thought was kind of a silly idea
you crushed it though and i said
i said if i just ignore these people
it'll go away
so i tried that that didn't work every
place i went there were people with
placards run been run i had over 500 000
petitions in my office
and uh
i finally just said lord you know i
don't want to run for president
you know my life is relatively peaceful
and i said
besides that i don't have all the things
that people who run for president have a
rolodex with all the important names an
organization a bunch of money i said
if i had all those things
i might consider it the next thing i
knew i had all those things had an
organization raising more money than the
rnc each month i mean it was ridiculous
but
what was fascinating uh during the
process
was traveling all over this country
to the smallest little hamlets
in north dakota or alabama
and what i discovered is the american
people
for the most part have common sense
they really do all over this country
not so much not so much in washington
d.c
but i mean throughout the country yeah
it's pretty amazing
and
a lot of stuff that comes out of dc does
not represent the people
this is a really big disconnect here
that's going on
and we have got to get people
good people
to get into government not just in
elected positions
but also
the career government employs
you know how they say it's dirty
politics is dirty okay well if there's
anybody that's gonna know if it is or if
it isn't so is it dirtier than you
thought or is it dirty as is exactly
what you how dirty you thought it was
going to be well when i went there i
knew it was a swamp
uh
i found out it was worse than that it's
a cesspool
can you unpack that you know examples of
why you think it is well for instance i
was
convinced that
if i became secretary of housing and
urban development
we would be able to put forward programs
that would allow people
through their own efforts to climb out
of poverty
and i said everybody should be
on board with this
and i was pretty amazed
with how vehemently opposed
some people on the hill were to people
becoming
independent
because if people become independent
you can't control their votes
you can't be their savior
that's a real pro it's a real problem
and everybody has
you know their own little pet projects
and things that they want
and they don't really care
about the nation as a whole is that left
and right you're not just saying one
side both sides one side more so than
the other but uh
yeah it's it's rampant throughout
washington and and it's so important
and one of the one of the things that we
have at american cornerstone
is something called executive 101
series
uh and we have multiple interviews on
there uh from people in government
positions to tell how those government
positions work and how they interact
and a host of other things because we
want people not to think of government
as something that's mysterious
and we want good people
to know what they're potentially getting
into but if we leave it only for the bad
folks what are we going to wind up with
with your with your role as the director
of the hud right um
you talk about you thought it was a
swamp it turned out to be a cesspool
what was your role supposed to be in
your mind and then what did it actually
turn out to be because i don't think a
lot of people really understand what it
is to be the director of housing and
urban development
uh walk us through that well what you
really want to do is
you know create adequate housing
you want to address the homelessness
problems uh that people have which were
are severe in this country
affordable housing issues
you know we actually uh we're making
excellent progress with one of the worst
places which is los angeles
uh working with the democratic mayor
garcetti
with the governor newsom with the county
executives we'd actually come up with a
very good plan
and then covert hit
but it is possible to work together
and uh you know that's what i saw my
role as i i think it's so important
that we don't give up
on being able to work together because
we the american people are not each
other's enemies
but we're allowing
people
to foment
hatred
and division among us and we we've got
to have
some leadership that understands what's
going on
and is
willing to provide the kind of example
without compromising our safety
how difficult was it to actually work
together you gave an example working
with
garcetti and newsome we're able to work
with uh de blasio we're able to work
with a lot of
people that most people on the right
would say oh those people are hopeless
is that something unique to your
abilities to find compromise was that
something from the
top down that came you know i think you
have to be willing to do it
you have to be willing to
actually sit down you have to be willing
to be able to look at the facts you have
to be able to understand
what things can be compromised
where can you meet in the middle and
what things are principles that cannot
be compromised and who was
the voice of reason or who are you who
are you
relying on to say hey this is the agenda
work with them don't work with them was
it were you working directly with
president trump on that was that your
team i would keep him informed yeah you
know he
sometimes wasn't particularly
enthusiastic about people like de blasio
but would you believe fantastic about
you and what you were looking to do he
was was it part of his agenda he was
very supportive so here's a question so
how did you guys go from
on stage you know back and forth the
comments you would make all of that
stuff how do you set that aside and then
say okay i'm gonna work with this guy
how do you do that well
for me it's because it's not about me
it's about america
it's about what can we do
to make this
the kind of place that it was supposed
to be
how can it be this shiny city on the
hill the place of hope it can't be that
if everything is about me
and correct me if i'm wrong you're one
of the few cabinet members that actually
made it through all four years is that
right that's correct okay
why do you think so many people weren't
able to last a year two years three
years four years like you is it attitude
is it mindset is it the relationship
with trump what was your unique skill
set there were a number of reasons you
may remember
early on first of all
how difficult it was for us to get our
assistant secretary's deputy secretaries
through i didn't have an assistant
secretary for the first five months
through the senate you're saying yeah to
get confirmed and i didn't have a deputy
secretary for eight months
uh i think they hoped that if they
didn't give me my people i would get
discouraged and go away but they don't
know me
you don't know me y'all you don't know
dr ben carson uh and we we got the right
people but
you remember how
they made accusations against almost all
of the secretaries
and there are all kinds of
claims made in my case
you know he bought this 31 000 dining
room table
and yet he's trying to cut
uh funding for poor people
uh you know that was the narrative that
they wanted
uh
obviously it wasn't true
and but the ig had to waste a million
dollars of taxpayers money doing an
investigation which of course showed
nothing because there was nothing to
show
and then that didn't work so they said
well carson's wife has an office at hud
and his sons are involved in running the
organization
that was a two million dollar taxpayer
which showed nothing because another
thing was none of it was true
but
bear in mind during all that you know i
had to
hire personal lawyers because they don't
cover that
and i spent tens of thousands of dollars
one of my sons spent over 150 000
you know defending himself
um
and there were some of the secretaries
who couldn't afford that
a hundred fifty thousand dollars your
son spent
so
you know for them it was
easier just to drop out and easier to
leave the cabinet you're saying rather
than deal with the drama and just
and and the finances are you talking as
far as i mean chief of staff came and
went generals came and went he's trying
to say it's more expensive to have a job
you know you know than to just say yeah
i'll resign and have somebody else do
this job is that kind of how i'm reading
this uh
they just did not have the money to find
it that's that's expense so so so if i
get this job and i'm
what do you get paid for secretary what
two hundred thousand dollars okay i mean
two hundred thousand dollars okay not a
whole lot of them no it's not a whole
lot not when you're a doctor and you're
making you know five excellent amount i
assume right yeah so but even we even
with that so a lot of these guys that
get those jobs
they get sued or not even sued
investigation you have to hire
accountants you have to hire a lawyer so
the cost of that
sometimes it's more than the salary
they're getting paid without question so
why take the job
well a lot of people you know want to do
things for their fellow americans they
want to serve
oh my god yeah well you're talking about
it like go wilbur ross for example that
guy's
right well money was a lot of money with
that exactly so a lot of people take
jobs when the government this is the
pat's point the final 20 years of a lot
of people's lives breaking news a lot of
people in politics are over 60 i don't
know if you know that but like not a lot
of young people involved in in congress
and and
certain cabinet members but
so a lot of people already have made
their money and have already made their
career so they're almost it's giving
back pat talks about this all the time
the four chapters of your career number
one uh first 20 years is don't screw it
up don't end up in jail don't kill don't
know any issues and now we can talk
about that your first 20 your second 20
years i believe is make your money
that's exactly what pat did
third uh third chapter is
pursue passions right pursue things that
you care about and the fourth chapter is
give back right so you're in uh
the give back phase a lot of people in
congress are in the give back or in uh
politics or in the give back phase so
a lot of people you're talking about the
people didn't have the money but they
did though a lot of those people well a
lot of the people who dropped out didn't
they other people who dropped out didn't
have the money right makes sense who who
who would you like to see run that is
not going to be running for example but
we don't know who's not going to well
maybe maybe that that hasn't ran yet i'm
not talking about the typical names that
we see i'm not talking cruz rubio
huckabee i'm not talking walker you know
at one point star jeb i'm not talking
those guys who would you like to see ron
we know desantis trump so take the usual
suspects out that everybody's talking
about okay you want some dark horses i i
want to know like if you you know like i
have some names i sit and i say i would
love to see that guy run i would love to
see this person run who would you like
to see ron well bear in mind
you know
20 years ago
or you know before clinton became the
nominee
no one knew this far ahead that he was
going to be the guy
and there are a lot of very very smart
people
in our country
and
i would like to see
some of those people who've been very
successful
maybe even in more than one endeavor
which shows that
they have the ability
to assess situations
you need somebody who has some wisdom
wisdom is much more important than
experience
you look at
a lot of people who are successful in
the political arena who had no political
experience before it's because they're
wise
they know how to listen
and then to integrate information
into an appropriate
pattern of thinking
that's the kind of person
or persons are you are you teasing us is
that what you're doing can we get a
couple names is there anybody that you
would say
could be a businessman a businesswoman
could be
a current congress men women senate
governor
tv show host you know
military uh any names
i don't want to give a name really
but are there any are there any but i
just want to give the criteria
i understand what kind of people are
what would you know i like to see what
kind of people would i support
uh
are you a sports guy or a movie person
or no you
no not particularly no you don't like
movies
did you ever see that one movie gifted
hands with the cubicle
that's a pretty good actor pretty good
he played a very interesting you know
brilliant man they actually did a very
good job with that movie i probably had
12
different movie producers who wanted to
do a movie
but they all believed
in
artistic license
and you know how hollywood
they would have had me having an affair
with some icy nurses
i said forget about that
but uh this group did it the right way
they consulted with me and did you
notice how realistic the operating room
scenes were
those were real surgeons and operating
room nurses
that we recruited from local hospitals
wow
so let me was cuba good junior the
person you wanted him to start he was
your number one guy yeah and he came
and spent some some time with me
studying my mannerisms and things like
that it's very good so so if he was the
guy can you give us the person that you
would want to run maybe if you don't
want to say the name
what business is this person in what's
their background well uh
again the the background isn't as
important as whether they were
successful so the key to you is purely
successful i need people who try to do
things
and are effective in doing them
because those are people who are using
their noggin
and that's what we need people who are
smart and people who care about others
you know
we started my wife and i started the
carson scholars fund 25 years ago
and it was because we noted some
surveys looking at the ability of our
students to achieve academically
and there are 22 countries
and we came in number 21 out of 22 in
math and science we were horrified
and
so we said we need to find a way to
encourage our kids and i'd be going into
these schools and giving talks and there
were all these trophies all state
basketball state wrestling i'll say this
that now
what about the academic superstars what
did they get
national honor society pin
pat on the head they're their little
nerd you know
be together we said we got to start
doing some so we started the program
where we would identify students as
early as the fourth grade
who were academic superstars did you
know you had to have at least a 3.75
grade point amateur on a 4.0 scale
that was the first part of the second
part you had to demonstrate that you
cared about other
people more than just the six weeks
before the application was due
and because you know hitler was smart
marquita thought it was smart but they
didn't care about other people
and we're trying to develop future
leaders for our country we need people
who are smart
and who care about other people
and you know the program started in
baltimore it expanded now it's in all 50
states and washington dc last year we
gave out our 10 000th
and we also have a reading room program
we put in these reading rooms
primarily targeting title one schools
where kids come from homes with no books
or very few books go to schools with
poorly funded libraries they're not
likely to become readers
but if you can get a kid reading at
grade level by third grade it changes
the trajectory of their lives their
likelihood of graduating from high
school
increases dramatically
and so we started putting in these
readings we've now put in over 250
uh around the country those are the
kinds of things that affect people's
lives
sure in other words first of all that's
incredible that you've done that over
the years but
is that a way of you saying that you'll
be running is that kind of what you're
saying uh
i
really don't want to get back into that
dr carson the um
you you actually give a whole entire
speech on being wise at php yeah so it's
you're very smart clearly uh doctor
you're very wise i think it's very
evident that you do care about america
and you don't put yourself first you put
america first
um you're clearly a strategist you know
what you're doing you're not you're not
very intentional
this is now two times that pat has asked
you hey what who would you like to see
run i don't want to name names and then
hey you know there's people tearing up
america there's people tearing up the
country the globalists who are they i
don't want to name names
respect i'm not i don't think this
question is going to pull names out but
i do want to ask why is it difficult to
maybe name some names is it
part of hey listen i don't want to pick
sides i don't want to call people out i
don't want to walk us through that
because it it puts undue attention or
pressure on people
and
that's
not something that i want to do what's
wrong with putting pressure on people
well well
here's here's one thing
i will say
find if it's somebody that's a teammate
but if somebody that is in the way of
hurting america don't you think we need
to do that
well people who are hurting america
should we come out against them is that
what you're saying yeah yeah of course
okay so when i asked you in the last 20
years who were some of the people you
didn't say any names would there be any
specific names that are globalist that
maybe behind closed doors are more
driven by power then you take somebody
like george soros who
is a hungarian and has been banned from
hungary
that should tell you a lot
you know a man who aided the nazis
who is funding these district attorneys
who are turning
you know violent criminals back out on
the streets to terrorize the population
i don't i don't mind
naming
that kind of evil mm-hmm so soros is on
that list would you would you say that a
klaus schwab is on the list or the
rothschilds on that list or clinton's uh
bushes on that list
uh i would not go that far okay
klaus schwab no
i mean when you think of globalist world
economic forum he's the top of the
spirit i'm not saying whether he's on or
off the list i i know much more
about the one that we just talked about
soros got it hey we got a name i respect
thank you
uh dr carson there's a few things that
you said earlier that have really just
been uh
hanging out in my mind and you said that
that people are trying to change america
from the inside due to power
and i think that brings a sense of
maliciousness and malice to it and it's
it's no secret that the temperature in
the country is high even trump just came
out and said we need to lower the
temperature so and you recently said
that it's not about you it's about
making america what it was always set
out to be so i wonder
if these people that are trying to
change the country the globalists if you
will if it if it is truly power and if
there is malice behind it or if it's
just hubris and arrogance and it's it's
a sort of expert class that thinks they
know better is there a difference is it
power is it malicious because again if
you bring that that raises the
temperature and i wonder what people
if if people need to lower the
temperature or if they really need to
understand that this is
people are trying to control you people
are trying to do something evil well
remember i also said that it is a
natural tendency of mankind
uh you can go back through history
people want control
and not only of their own lives but of
people around them and that's why the
founders of our country were
extraordinarily diligent individuals
and they studied every governmental
system that has ever existed
they were eclecticists
they they
took the good things
and they abandoned the bad things
and they use that to put together our
constitution in an attempt
to keep
people
from taking control
of everybody else that was the whole
purpose of our constitution
you got your answer to your question
yeah yeah okay so so i think it seems as
though it is
the human tendency to be malicious it is
okay can we go into someone can we go
into some issues is that okay with you
if we go into some uh i love issues all
right let's do that let's go into some
issues here that we have
first issue uh who would you like to see
run
[Laughter]
this is mccarthyism
biden science inflation reduction act
into law this is a cnn story i'm reading
president joe biden signs a sweeping 750
billion dollar health care tax and
climate bill into law at the white house
on tuesday the act accomplishes several
key binding legislative agenda items
representing the largest climate
investment in american history and
making major changes
to health policy by giving medicare the
power for the first time to negotiate
the price of certain prescription drugs
and extending
expiring health care studies for three
years the legislation will reduce
legislation will reduce the deficit be
paid
for through new taxes including a
fifteen percent minimum tax on large
corporations and a five one percent tax
on stock buybacks and boost the internal
revenue service ability to collect it
will raise over 700 billion dollars in
government revenue over 10 years and
spend over 430 billion dollars to reduce
carbon emissions and extend subsidies
for health insurance under the
affordable care act and use the rest of
the new revenue to reduce the deficit
thoughts on the new bill
well i think it should be offensive to
most people
because it assumes that people are
simple enough
to believe that if you name something
inflation reduction act that that's what
it is
and of course that's not what it is it's
a
government
intrusion into your life act
and it massively expands
you know government agencies like the
irs
87 000 irs agents what do you think 87
000 irs agents are there to do
they are there
to
try to get more of your money
and
it's not going to just be the
billionaires and the multi-millionaires
you could take all of their money it
won't be enough the way our government
is spending at this point so you got to
go where the money is
it's sutton's law sudden the famous
train robber they said why do you rob
why do you rob banks he said because
that's where the money is
well
and
so the government knows where the money
is it's in the middle it's in the middle
class and that's why they need so many
agents to go in and get it
but
you know also interfering with the way
business is conducted you know this uh
one percent
uh tax
for stock buybacks
that's going to have an impact
on businesses
uh in america
one of the reasons that
america was so successful is because we
created an atmosphere that encouraged
entrepreneurship and innovation
and didn't have a ton of
interference that was one of the things
that alexis de tocqueville noted when he
came to america to study us in 1831
because the europeans were fascinated
they couldn't understand how a nation
barely 50 years old was already
competing with them on virtually every
level how was that possible well our
business model was one of the things
that he noted he also noted
that we had
a government
that worked because we had checks and
balances
and he also noted that we had an
educational system that was superior he
could find a mountain man in the middle
of the woods and a guy could read
the guy could tell you about the
declaration of independence
if you want to be impressed go back and
look up
a
sixth grade exit exam from the 1800s see
what you had to know to get a sixth
grade certificate it's pretty impressive
especially when you look at some of
those men on the street interviews that
we have today you go out and you ask
people listen they have no idea what
you're talking about
and so true you know this is a real
problem because if people aren't
knowledgeable
they're very easy to manipulate
and uh you know our history is so
important the good the bad and the ugly
it's all important because your history
gives you your identity and your
identity is the basis of your beliefs
and if you interrupt that chain you
become a leaf blowing in a win so
standards and expectations are dropping
when it comes down to education
severely
and you know this this bill is just a
gigantic intrusion
of government
into our lives and this nation was
supposed to be different it was supposed
to be about the people not about the
government
let me let me ask you this did you see
the video with the irs agents being
trained on how to use a gun did you see
that video i want to show that clip here
in a minute but before you do before you
play this clip by the way this video is
gonna
you'd be blown away by this video but
hang tight before i play this video
just to how long ago was yuvaldi seven
weeks how long ago was yuvaldi is it is
it uh two months ago two months ago
so eight weeks ago
so you've only happens the biggest
discussion was
why aren't we you know putting a an
armed cop
at schools nationwide now even if we
don't put them in the best communities
let's just say the bottom 80 percent of
communities that are maybe not the
safest right why don't we put a cop in
all these places
and invest resources into that so so the
question then becomes and by the way if
you're listening i'm curious you know if
you agree with us give it a thumbs up if
you don't give it a thumbs down i want
to actually hear your thoughts on this
here
if you're willing to use your taxpayer
money
where you get 87 000 irs agents
who are being trained on how to use a
gun way to see this video versus 87 000
cops to put at schools to protect
another yuvaldi from happening
which investment would you be willing to
vote for more and say i'm willing to pay
taxpayer dollar for the 87 000 cops at
public schools versus 87 000 irs agents
to come after me what would you rather
invest in so to me it's a logical sure
answer to question
how is logic not winning today
because you have
politicians who are not interested in
what's good for the people
so
and why do people keep voting for these
guys though i mean you can't see the
people are dumb why are they voting i'm
so glad you asked that question
because
this is a failure
on behalf of many american citizens they
go into the voting booth
and they look for the name that looks
familiar
no they just look for the r or the d
or they do that
and uh you know it could be satan they
say oh yeah i know that one.
in many cases it is
that's a problem
we have to be diligent we can't take
this privilege seriously of voting and
you know that's a whole another topic
you know the the voting system
in our country right now is looking at
an interview
uh yesterday
uh individual from france talking about
their system
and why
is it that they're able to have the
results
the same night
or two days later at the latest
uh well they use paper ballots
they save them they have
there's no mail-in uh at all
they used to have that they stopped it
in 1975
and the question was asked why'd you
stop it because there was so much
cheating it was too easy to cheat
um
why don't we learn from some of these
things
why don't we learn about voting cheating
because we want voting cheating
that would be the only reason
because we want voting cheating right
now you're going to the 2000 mules uh
you know you're going to a whole
different section now i don't even have
to go to that section i just say
when's the last time we had an election
where people didn't think there was
cheating
you know when trump was elected the
first time he's not my president no they
cheated that didn't work you know
obama they said yeah there was problem
kennedy they said there was i mean
why don't we invest
some of that effort
that allow us to put a man on the moon
to have an election system that's open
apparent and that everybody can agree on
why don't we do that why don't we do
that because
people have found that they can
manipulate the system are you convinced
of that
absolutely like how certain are you when
you say this is this like 90 or you 100
convinced that this happens well
france
which is a left-wing country sure
i mean if they can understand
that the system
that they were using
you know subjected itself to a lot of
cheating and they rejected it
why wouldn't we learn from their example
and that's a socialist country
the issues they have is real but they
show they choose they vote for socialism
if they don't have mail-in ballots
uh i don't want to get into
france's politics uh
but if you're saying there's no cheating
them in their socialistic nations still
that means majority nation prefer
socialism over capitalism only to say
that
they have come up with a system that
they
understand that's transparent and that
their people agree with
and we need to do the same thing
so interesting can you play that clip
can you play that clip of this and then
i'll tell you fast have you seen this
yet or no i have not seen of the irs
you've seen this okay so make them make
it bigger just just full screen and
press play and i'll tell you fast
forward it so first you just see them
walking up and you're like okay
maybe these are new irs grads they're
excited they're celebrating how cool is
this
isn't this awesome we're about to go
play with some
i don't know
you know arcade or we're gonna do some
monopoly then go to
minute one go to one minute halfway
through halfway look at this
[Music]
look at how that guy's holding it
those thumbs you can tell he was in the
military before yeah
what are they saying can you hear that
no they're role-playing as i'm saying
what are the questions they ask
ira special agent
this is real by the way this is not a
movie
this is not saturday night live no this
is true this is not a spoof this is not
a skit this is not vincent orsana
this is real okay
this is not
he's at nancy pelosi's office type of
situation this is really
a training that they're doing with the
new irs agency is this
very interested in knowing if there's
ever been a training like this before
under any
presidential uh regime is this is this
new have you ever seen anything like
this i haven't seen anything like it
i've never seen anything like this it's
extremely worrisome well the irs has
been weaponized for for years now
whether or not the training happened
they've had millions and millions of
dollars in weapons and ammunition for
years yeah how long
10 years 15 years
so this this goes over multiple
presidents why does the irs need weapons
because
as in any tyrannical state
you have to rule by fear
yeah but according to our friend tyler
over here this has been going on for
decades
official reports where are we saying
tyrannical are you saying the american
we've been marching up toward
tyranny
and we're getting close to the top of
the staircase
so
this is uh from forbes
uh official report says at the end of
2017 the tax agency had
4487 guns and over 5 million rounds of
ammunition in its weapons inventory this
was published by the excuse me published
by the government accountability office
um so and this was a report at the end
of 2017 so who knows how long they've
had the weapons for right you don't buy
4 500 guns in a year but walk me through
why the irs would need
weapons uh to intimidate people
to make people understand
that you could die if you don't
do what we tell you to do
this is like literally what who's the
guy that said uh why do you rob banks no
that's where the money is that's that's
the well the physical representation of
that they have to come and get your
money
how how else are they going to continue
this ridiculous spending
where are they coming up and
give me your tax revenue are they going
to businesses are they going to
individuals they go into corporations
when is this well it's all happening
obviously they're not going to be going
up to the billionaires
and the people that they claim that
they're going after
they're going to be coming after average
joe
that's why they need so many people
with guns with guns
and they've been practicing i saw an
article
yesterday or the day before
of
raiding homes and suburbs
i mean
i if if this is not a wake-up call for
us i i don't know what it is
i'd like to know who leaked that video
or like who put that video out there
this is very disconcerting regardless of
your life how do you feel about it
obviously that's how you feel about it
that's why i'm like what is this what is
happening exactly like when they're
doing these classes who's putting these
classes on who who's running the show
here
anyone
left or right if you don't see this and
say i don't think that's exactly too
comforting yeah you're missing the point
and and this is not really a democrat or
republican issue
this is an issue of america and american
freedom i agree on who we are as a
nation
and uh you know people have got to wake
up
i think they are waking up to be honest
with you i i think
things have been pushed so rapidly that
a lot of the people who were slumbering
are waking up yeah yeah you know how
they're saying they're targeting
billionaires you know how many
billionaires we have in america how many
billionaires do we have in america right
now
maybe a couple hundred between seven and
eight hundred that's not a big number so
we got 330 billion people oh you're
getting 87 000 irs agents to catch 700
people yeah you're trying to get 700
people that are billionaires to go after
them give me a break the math doesn't
make any sense so so but it's such great
storytelling you got to give them credit
on the ability to tell the stories that
we're targeting
billionaires and we're going after them
you don't need 87 for 700 billion well
class warfare and envy
is a tool
that politicians have used forever many
years they're trying to get their way
and
you know why won't they ever tell you
for instance
what is a fair share
for rich people to pay
that number the top 1 pays 37 of the
federal income tax
37
is that not fair that one percent could
pay 37 percent
they won't ever tell you the answer to
that okay can i ask you a follow-up on
this so
this um
inflation reduction act i
was initially supposed to be the build
back better right uh biden agenda it got
uh lampooned by
essentially joe manchin
who would have been the 50th boat or
kamala would have been the 51st boat
yeah kristen cinema as well very
disappointed um yeah and he held out for
a year and and behind closed doors he
was working with biden or uh chuck
schumer
to manifest this or bill gates or bill
gates allegedly
what what do you think joe manchin who
has been you know iconic on the right
these days and uh blasphemed on the left
and now he's being propped up again you
know joe manchin can't win or he can't
lose depending on who
the time of day what do you think
happened there why did he co-sign this
well because this bill wouldn't happen
with that joe manchin right i i asked
them once i said uh joe why don't you
just become a republican you said this
to him yeah right and he said
there's got to be somebody on the other
side
with some sense
which i assume you applaud no yeah i i
say yeah that's right
until you lose that sense
what happened
in less than a month where he had this
major common sense and now he gave into
this what do you think happened i
believe it's possible to apply a lot of
pressure to people
and i'm sure he felt that pressure
and
you know he probably knows
that this is going to cost him his
senate seat
uh but i suspect that
you know he weighed the possible
things that could happen to him
both good and bad
from a financial point of view and he
said
i'll find a way to to make
this work yeah but
with mansion
nothing was happening with the bind
agenda unless manchin said yes so he
could have said listen i agree with all
this okay the you know uh inflation uh
medicare
green uh climate okay cool cool
but the irs i'm not good with this and
that could have been
killed right and they said all right
well
because biden has corrected me if i'm
wrong three more months to get some [ __ ]
done right because in the midterms it's
expected to be a bloodbath so he needed
to get something done
mansion could have just held strong and
said all right we want this we want this
don't want this
why would a mansion want something like
87 000 irs agents how does that benefit
at all well we're not going to know
because we don't know what those private
conversations were
but i'm sure they were very convincing
well bloom bloomberg says it was bill
gates
bloomberg says
let me read that story can i read that
story yeah is that the story you're
talking about yeah okay page four i'm
gonna read the story real quick
bloomberg news exposes
expos exposes eco hypocrite billionaire
bill gates involvement to save biden's
climate bill
um
gates reportedly didn't just start his
secret efforts to influence manchin and
other u.s legislators to adopt his
radical utopian vision on climate as
gates revealed to bloomberg green
he has quietly lobbied manchin and other
senators starting with biden had won the
white house in anticipation of a rare
moment in which heavy federal spending
might be secured for the clean energy
transition bloomberg said when manchin
expressed hesitancy to supporting new
climate spending gates reportedly saw a
unique opportunity
he taped uh tapped into a relationship
with mansion that he'd cultivated for at
least three years we were able to talk
even at a time when we when he felt
people weren't listening gates
reportedly told bloomberg biden signed
the mammoth climate bill today thanks to
mansion's newfound support during a
ceremony at the white house
how do you i mean there's a lot of
people on the right that actually like
mansion how do you read this article
when you when you hear something like
this i think uh mansion was given a
offer he couldn't refuse
wow you're going godfather's stuff
got it interesting
interesting and
mansion was just interviewed yesterday
by a fox reporter and said you know you
voted for this
inflation reduction act
when is it going to reduce inflation and
he some said something along the lines
of will it won't it's not like turning
on a switch it's not going to reduce
inflation these people are well aware
that this is a ridiculous title for this
bill i mean you're pumping what 640
billion dollars in the economy it's
ridiculous
yeah well when when somebody does
something
they make a 180 degree turn around you
don't have a good explanation
um
it's usually because of something that
they don't want you to know and that's
mansion is who you're alluding to yes
interesting
but it's not unique to kind of
no no
put a nice little name like the cares
act under trump exactly like the cares
that all right
and even the bill that was the the heels
act the hope act every every
bill that becomes a law is giving a
little marketable name to it though it's
not unique unfortunately you know people
of america
have lost
faith
in our government because of things like
that
because of the way covet was handled
because of what happened in afghanistan
i mean there's just so many
why
why would you have faith in the
government anymore
and it's a severe problem
because if we don't get it back
you know pretty soon
we're
doomed
what is dr carson what does this say
about the state of american democracy
that that one senator holds so much
power in his hands
essentially that's what it's come down
to well i guess the question is
how did it get to the point
that we're so
polarized
that one person could have that kind of
power so you don't think this is a
failure in democracy or the way
government functions you think this is a
polarization
it's a polarization issue
well i don't think there's any doubt
that america is polarized and if you
want to use the word tribal but let's
give a little respect to joe manchin for
a second because
how many
democrats are getting elected in the
reddest state in the union i mean here's
someone
exactly so
you pride yourself on not making about
yourself working with other people
putting your hand across the aisle
essentially what joe manchin has done
for 40 years so do you think something
actually changed in the last 30 days
yeah or like you think something
happened yeah i think they made an offer
it kind of refused and what does that
what does that sound like like behind
closed doors what does that mean i mean
is that death threats is that money is
that uh legacy what is it it could be
any of those things but
he is not a stupid person no
and
you know he weighed
things and says
how do i end up
best off mm-hmm
and he made that decision
so you think he'll just ride off into
the sunset never look for reelection
again you don't think because he helped
pass biden's agenda that the people of
west virginia are going to be done you
have a hard time with this because
you're a big fan of mansion i do like
i know and and by the way most
people do i i i mean you're not in uh a
company where you're the only guy that
likes him what he's saying is there was
an offer made that he can refuse what
that is he doesn't know i don't think
anybody knows but when a guy named bill
gates gets involved
you're talking about a guy that's got a
lot of ex did you see him when he was
young and he was sitting there going up
against the lawyer have you ever seen
those conversations he had with the
lawyer when he was younger have you ever
seen that video or no yeah of how he
handled a lawyer
do you know that whole scene where mark
zuckerberg where the guy plays him in
social networks do you know that's where
the
practice came from watching how gates
handled it you're not talking to a
lightweight guy you're talking about a
guy that
he's been he's gotten criticism of
having asperger's which means
emotions low you know this and obviously
he's known for having a temper but you
know at the same time when a guy like
gates gets involved he's got many
creative ways of pushing things through
right he's not a lightweight this is a
very heavyweight guy that got involved
so now on the flip side i'm on the flip
side of this okay before we go into the
story with fbx i definitely want to hear
what you have to say about that elon
musk featured at a kevin mccarthy gop
retreat in wyoming just kind of weird
okay
so you read the story billionaire llama
spoke at a republican retreat hosted by
house majority leader kevin mccarthy uh
in wyoming on tuesday the event came in
at the same day as representative liz
cheney the former number three house
republican lost the primary challenge to
harriet
hageman who was supported by former
president trump mccarthy is sourced
familiar with the retreat confirmed
musk's attendance at the event which
included republican candidate supporters
according to fox news mccarthy musk that
a closed press fireside chat with
supporters musk has donated to both
republicans and democrats in the past
and has donated to mccarthy's campaign
dating back to 2011 according to federal
election commission data but the
billionaire has said that until last
year he had only voted for democrats the
first republican he voted for his
representative
myra flores from texas mosque signed a
signal they tweet tuesday that he's not
supportive of the far-right faction of
the party to be clear i support the left
half of the republican party and the
right half of the democratic party what
are your thoughts when you see
a musk being at a kevin mccarthy event
and kevin mccarthy is one of the most
hated guys on the left
well
you know i don't have a problem with it
to be honest with you
uh i think you got to listen to
all points of view
and elon musk is an important voice
um
you know particularly
since he may at some point on twitter
so i don't think it's
necessarily a bad thing to cultivate a
relationship with him
i don't agree with
a lot of stuff that he does or says
but that doesn't mean that we shouldn't
keep the communications open i agree and
i i fully agree with you there the the
question the challenge becomes
if the nominee is a trump
and the two of them had a back and forth
on twitter where he calls him another
[ __ ] artist and then he comes out
and says look i think we should just
kind of
move away from politics and i think the
moment your age starts with number seven
you shouldn't run anymore and they had
that back and forth
how this is gonna look if the nominee is
trump would musk support a trump if he
is the nominee or would he go the other
side
uh
i don't know
that would be pretty interesting let's
see what happens there it would be
interesting
but but that's one of the reasons that i
think it's important
to keep the channels of communication
open you said that earlier yeah the
dialogue is so vitally important but
what's the difference between a musk
sitting down with the kevin mccarthy you
know number one guy in the in the house
and a um
man and a gate sitting down with joe
manchin isn't that exactly the same
thing a billionaire speaking with a
major political figure that's exactly
yeah that's exactly why i brought the
support the story right afterwards the
only difference is is the following
this is the only difference between the
two
whose motives
do you trust more do you trust bill
gates's motives or do you trust elon
musk's motives that's the decision you
got to make because you know like let's
just say if somebody is trying to judge
you
and they say who's in adam's here they
said well patrick bedevils and adam's
here if pat if a person doesn't trust
patrick they may say i don't want
patrick but they've been in adam's ear
right and so let me tell you who's in
that guy's ear so you have to sit there
and say would you rather have an elon
musk in someone's here or bill gates in
someone's ear the voter has to decide
that because
both of them are the top five most
powerful people in the world when it
comes down to money you can only add a
couple other names to that list you can
ask bezos and maybe a couple other guys
but they're both in the top five at any
given moment so sure who do you trust
more gates or musk
and by the way they've got some some
internal beef themselves right who do
you trust more gates or musk who do you
who do you think has more of a best
interest for america between the two
uh
personally i would
come down on the musk side okay yeah and
what's the what's the
the biggest reason why
uh because you already said that you're
not a big fan of musk right right but
because
of his
concern
about freedom of speech
and like i said i don't agree with him
on everything but i think freedom of
speech is such a vital part of who we
are as a nation and what's your do you
have a beef with bill gates is there
something about bill gates you're like i
don't really uh like what he's doing
with that thing what would that be well
i i think his uh tremendous emphasis on
the climate
uh above everything else
is problematic for me
what do you think his motive is with
their speculation
i think he
kneels at the altar of climate like so
many others on the left
and
because of that
they believe themselves to be righteous
and when they believe themselves to be
righteous anybody who opposes
them you know you can lie to them you
can do anything you want to them
and uh i i don't
agree with that kind of philosophy
how about yourself you trust gates more
you trust muskmore
um
can you answer that or is this one of
those
yeah i mean of the two i would trust a
musk more okay cool just curious one i i
didn't know if you were a microsoft guy
or a tesla yeah i'm neither more however
i i i don't know enough about bill gates
and his agenda i do understand the
climate stuff and he's been working on
that especially vaccine stuff in africa
i mean there's a lot to applaud with
what she's done i don't know there's a
lot of people that think he's doing very
evil stuff there's a lot of people that
go down you know the tinfoil hat route
with him and the world economic forum
and the q a like he gets labeled that i
don't know if he's that bad of an actor
i don't know
it's okay to question that i'm sure he
had some some good qualities and you
know i knew his dad
um much more so than him i bill gates
dad sat on the board with his dad really
yeah
who's his father
bill gates senior oh really yeah i
didn't know that
the moment somebody says i knew is that
conversation changed a little bit
so so let's talk about fbi i got a bunch
of stories here about the fbi but i just
open-ended questions so when you heard
about the raid fbi merrick garland you
know and then biden comes out you know
he says i had no idea about this this is
a decision that the fbi made this didn't
come all the way up to me
and then three people came in they left
the cameras on and they weren't supposed
to put the body cameras on they asked
the attorneys to step out they got the
27 boxes they found four highly
classified and then two you know three
and then three we've read all the
stories you've read it i've read it
you what do you what do you just what do
you think about the whole situation
well
uh i'm troubled by it
because you know if they were concerned
about these documents
why did they wait a year and a half
after the president has been out of
office
and
if we have a justice system that is fair
why weren't they just as vigorous with
all the documents that hillary had
that
she didn't want anybody else to see
that she deleted
asset watch their hard drive
smash the blackberry phones
i mean
that's not what an innocent person does
but
no questions asked
um
same thing with hunter biden
so
could trump have done some things that
were inappropriate
yes
uh
have others done things that are
inappropriate yes
why do we put so much concentration on
one
and not on the others that's what i'm
concerned about i'm concerned about the
unfairness aspect
and
you know
i think
we need to
uncover the
the affidavit
and you can redact the names that you
know no one has to be uh identified
we need to know what's going on here
because this is
this is essential
to our trust
in the government and in our federal law
enforcement agencies
now at first they said they will then
they said they won because at risk of a
nation's security etc etc how much of
that is [ __ ] how much of that is
real well it's very easy to redact
what needs to be redacted yeah we need
to understand what it is that they were
looking for
the fourth
amendment
guarantees
protection against
unlawful search and seizure
so that should apply to everybody
including ex-presidents
probably even more there right i mean a
certain level of respect on
the way to to to handle that now
you know a video went not necessarily
viral but it's been shared all over the
place of ron paul okay it's a 1988
interview of ron paul i'm sure he saw
this where he says
you know for most of our country for
most of our history we didn't have these
institutions the fbi came and came in
during the first world war and
interestingly enough
the one thing woodrow wilson did he used
the fbi to spy on american citizens and
actually arrest them if they disagreed
with his foreign policy about going to
war in europe
isn't it interesting how recently they
used it in the vietnam era democrats
used it then republican used the fbi to
spy on 100 different groups in this
country including the churches who
disagree with the policy in central
america it almost looks like the fbi was
designed to spawn americans who disagree
with policy especially foreign policy do
you agree with ron paul
i think he has some very valid points
and you know i think this is a serious
issue
and i think
we need to as a nation bipartisan effort
uh
look into making sure that our agencies
do what they're supposed to do what you
do which of the agencies do you trust
the least
which one of them makes you the most
uncomfortable you got cia you got the
you got all these you know
fbi which one do you trust the best
agencies i'm not sure that i trust any
of them right now really
i'm not sure that i trust any of them
uh i that doesn't mean that all the
people in them are bad people sure some
of them are very good people sure
but uh you know we're looking at
agencies that are run by people who
perhaps
have other agendas
than protecting the american population
you know the debate right now it's very
easy for things to go viral you know
hashtags to go viral you know
defund the police you know came out a
year ago and democrats are now saying
it's a republican ideology right
and they're they're
actually convincing their base that this
is now their their idea
now it's and the fbi okay
then there's people that behind closed
doors say i don't know if we can get
away without cia without this what are
we going to do if we don't have the mi6
and these other guys got mossad and you
know they got their mi6 they got their
massage they got their this they got
their that then those are valid concerns
yes should we get rid of ci should we
get rid of fbi is it best to get rid of
them and if not what is the solution i i
don't think getting rhythm is the right
thing to do i think what we need to do
is like i said before make sure they're
doing what they're supposed to how do
you do that though i mean you you're
talking about an organization where
there's zero accountability to who
everything is secret they can use
everything to say well it's for your own
protection why we don't want to share
with you the details of what just took
place here with this investigation well
the oversight needs to be uh
tightened up
okay
uh you know
oversight was provided
through our constitution
and it specifically says for instance
that
road rogue judges
should be
uh evaluated by congress when's the last
time you saw congress evaluate a rope
judge
couldn't tell you
you know we we really need to take these
things seriously because our founders
recognize that these things would occur
and they didn't just put the stuff down
there so it can be on a test
it was it was really to protect us
prove your point uh i had our friend
tyler pull up the job ratings of the uh
key federal agencies and where they're
at
essentially pre-covered and now
uh and they many of them have declined
significantly uh top of the list
as far as declines go is the cdc it went
from 64
to 40 percent next on the list is the
cia
went from 60 to 41 minus 19
and then you have a handful of double
digits the fbi
went from 57 to 44 homeland security
um
55 to 42.
secret service has gone down 14 uh
the post office has gone down 17 74 57
but um nasa
exactly the same has gone down zero
percent so
space force let's keep that and keep
that going
but to your point a lot of federal
agencies have uh lost trust from the
american people and it's a serious
problem because if the people don't
trust the government
uh you're
sowing the seeds for
massive disturbances
but
okay
by the way story continues okay within
this topic daily beast
viper merrick garland's trump raid
is only the first inning okay democratic
strategist named james carville has a
message for people who are doubting
merrick garland just wait people are
like well but let's wait and see a
little bit and this is like the top of
the first inning i mean remember merrick
garland is like a pit viper he
prosecuted the oklahoma city bomber case
the unabomber case the olympic bomber
case and i think these guys are really
methodical trump and the mega
republicans defenses are just literally
absurd i mean absurd like he can
declassify anything he wants says
carville
plus you ask why did trump want all
these documents and the answer is the
most logical reason he was gonna sell
them right because he needs money right
a ridiculous thing to say but you're
talking about a guy that some call him
the democratic strategist you know this
is like the
brain that comes up with strategies this
is not just a
lightweight pundit from cnn or msnbc
saying something like this well you know
a lot of
former presidents have kept lots of
documents
uh you know obama it's in the millions
of documents
why do they keep them
well you know not everybody gets to be
president i mean it's just kind of cool
to have these documents
uh save them for prosperity save them
for your library which will eventually
be built
um
i don't think it necessarily
means that you have nefarious purposes
do you agree with them that this is just
the top of the first inning or is this
one of those things where adam schiff
got up and hey it's i know for a fact
there was a russia collusion like how do
you well i think because there's been so
much pushback
[Music]
they probably are going to
not be as aggressive
as they might have been before why
too much push right so so some people
say some people will say that you'll
talk to a democrat and democrats will
say
uh
well let me tell you this has got
nothing to do with election no one on
the left is afraid of
trump running for office that's
ludicrous he doesn't have that kind of
credibility anymore he lost it all you
know the left is not afraid of him
running again okay fine that's their
argument that's their wishful thinking
they don't want to see them run again
why don't they
because i mean look at the crowds that
come out and see him look at the
enthusiasm behind
that kind of
activity
you you don't want somebody who's going
to rally the troops
you want sort of a sleeper candidate
so yeah they would do everything they
can to make sure that he doesn't run
again
and that's why they're going to try to
find a way to indict him
because i don't think
while you're under indictment that you
can run for president even tucker said
that he thought that an indict would be
coming did you see tucker say that yeah
he he's he said well he said it's the
only logical thing coming
not that they're gonna have
valid reasons or there's anything that's
gonna come from it but it's it's the
logical next step when do you think
trump is going to make his announcement
that he's running again in 2024 before
or after midterm elections
i have no idea
dr benjamin carson sir
you must have a
hypothesis i guess
well let me just say
if if i were him
yes sir i would make it afterwards you
would do it after the midterms
what's your strategy there
the strategy there is that if if i do it
before
i might energize
a lot of people on the left to come out
and vote against
the people who are running
so
right after midterms right after the
bloodbath the expected bloodbath yes by
the way did you see what peter said
peter uh how do you pronounce this
yeah no peter strzok the fbi agent said
americans should absolutely
trust fbi after the trump raid
absolutely the american people should
trust what the fbi is doing
uh peter said the uh the fbi is head
investigated into alleged russian uh
meddling in 2016 elections and former
secretary of hillary clinton's private
email server he was removed from the
brief stint on robert mueller's special
counsel investigation after sending
anti-trump text messages and beginning
an affair with colleague lisa page and
was ultimately fired from the agency
from or for a text in august 2018 he
said
trump has spent his entire adult life
living on the margins
of the law pushing up the edge seeing
what he can get away with and then
pushing a step or two beyond that when
it when a guy like that
disgrace ex-fbi when a guy like that
says something like that how much
credibility does he have with the
american people
i don't think he has a lot of
credibility
anybody who
sees him as credible will probably see
anybody incredible
you were about to say the peter navarro
comment
peter navarro comment about you're
talking about a question about kushner
is that where you guys started what
you're talking about i was actually
going to this one that was the one i was
going to
last thing here before we wrap up dwyane
wade i want to go into the nba a little
bit because i know you're a big nba fan
so let's let's talk about the nba
predictions next season let's go yeah
we're not all 32 teams so doctor so a
couple things so it's important to our
democracy mba will not schedule games on
election day the nba will not be
scheduling games on on the midterm
election day but all 30 teams will play
the night before november 7. the league
looks to use
this as an opportunity to encourage its
fan base to go out and vote to amplify
the need for civic engagement the
election
will take plan on november 8th for all
435 seats and the u.s house of
representative and 30 u.s senate seats
along with
multiple uh
governor and state races it's unusual we
don't usually change the schedule for an
internal external event
said executive director of the nba
social justice coalition james uh
cadigan but voting and election day are
obviously unique and incredibly
important to our democracy
what do you think about the nba just
shutting down election for midterms
uh
i think they're welcome to do that um
i encourage everybody to go out and vote
and
every
agency every entity
should encourage that but let's do it
the right way that's the key thing
um
you know i was telling you about what
was going on in france
one of the things that the
french observer said
is that we require
photo identification
so i guess that makes us racist
he said that the french france guy he
said that who said that macron no no no
no the the french guy who was being
interviewed about about their election
system i don't understand the idea of
you know showing your id being racist i
have no idea what that is but remember
you got to show your racism
what's your i mean as a black man who's
very vocal about this is showing id
racist of course it's not racist of
course you want to know who's voting
you know if if there's something going
on in your neighborhood yeah that
affects the people in your neighborhood
do you want anybody to come in and vote
about it or maybe just the people in
your neighborhood
do you have uh family members or good
friends
uh black people that you disagree with
vehemently or disagree with you
vehemently about those type of topics of
course and how do you deal with that
uh just
stick to the facts
just talk about the facts no feelings
uh you know you can probably tell i'm
not a person who
heavily involved with emotion yeah but
you used to be i used to you were young
oh yeah
well you know god changed me really do
we have time for one last question
because i want to so
uh i do want to touch upon a dwayne
weight story okay guys well
you
rumor has it you used to have a very bad
temper i did and you've changed
significantly um ironically i i find a
lot of your story
um
very
similar to that of my father my father
was born in detroit same age as you uh
very bad temper he was picked on as a
kid
um
very similar story um
but you were able to change your temper
my father was not able to do that he had
a very bad temper uh he would fight
people i think you're you were you were
you were got bullied you bullied you
were you're a fighter
um you know pat talks about my question
essentially is how are you able to
change pat talks about all the time
about how you can change and how you can
improve you outwork you out improve you
out strategize you out last did i say
that correctly
um you were able to do all four of those
things what was the key there's a lot of
people out there saying i don't know
this is the life i live i don't know how
i'm gonna change i don't know how i'm
gonna do things i don't know how i can
improve i i'm stuck in this situation
nobody has changed and improved their
life as much as you i don't know that
you can do it on your own but
you know after i tried to stab another
teenager
i was in the bathroom and i was
contemplating my life and i realized
that i had changed things around
academically
i would become a student
but i said you're never going to be a
doctor with a temper like this you're
going to end up in jail reform school or
the grave and i said i don't like any of
those
and there was a bible and i picked it up
started reading from the book of
proverbs and there were all these verses
about anger like proverbs 19 19 there's
no point getting an angry man out of
trouble because he's just going to get
right back into it but also very
positive verses like proverbs 16 32.
mightier is the man of control his
temper than a man can conquer city and
while i was in there praying and
contemplating and reading
it dawned on me that the reason that i
was angry so often is because i was
selfish
it was always about me
somebody had done this to me they had
taken my thing i want this
and i said
if you step outside of the middle of the
circle
let it be about somebody else
you won't be angry
that was the last day i had an angry
outburst and you haven't been angry in
50 years is what you're saying
uh i general it takes a lot to make me
angry wow
you know my wife knows how
so that's the secret
the wife pissing you off powerful
what do you think about proverbs 38 17
there is no problem with 38 it says thou
shall end the fbi
[Laughter]
dwyane wade claims hatred of miami
heat's big three is because they were
black men if you recall the miami heat's
big three consists of dwyane wade lebron
james chris bosh j.j reddick pointed out
that some of the hate that dwyane wade
was receiving because a group of sports
fans that are and will always be
uncomfortable with black powerful black
men
uh making decisions for themselves
taking empowerment and controlling uh
taking control their careers the women
respond i agree with you and i didn't
say that but i'm glad you said that but
we felt that way we knew that some of
the hate was because of our skin color
because of the black men uh uh deciding
taking control of their faith of our
careers because organizations will do it
quickly they will trade a dwyane wade in
a heartbeat if you're not accomplishing
what they want you to
accomplish so when we had the power when
we had the moment we took it but some of
the hate came because we were three
black guys who decided and would change
the way that the nba probably would ever
be because of that decision so i agree
with you man 100 so what do you think
about that was that because they were
black men or was it just because i think
it's it's kind of uh
sad that so many things circle back
around to race
and they don't need to
that's that's why i wrote my most recent
book
you know called created equal
the painful past confusing
present and hopeful future of race in
america looking at racial issues from
both ends but
using objective evidence for instance
take the george floyd incident
it was played 24 7 incessantly
you would think that black unarmed black
men are being killed by police all the
time we had some friends in australia we
talked to them they said yeah they
played all the time what's going on over
there
what are the real statistics
the washington post
says
less than two dozen
incidents a year
with more than 50 million police
civilian and congress think about that
think about those numbers
so it's very rare it's a tragedy any
time it occurs
but
recognize how the media manipulates
people
and makes you think that things are very
different than they are there was
another case
that was very similar to this
same situation police with the knee on
the neck
face on the ground saying i'm gonna die
almost no coverage why
because the victim was white
it didn't fit the narrative
who cares
these are problems we've made enormous
progress in my lifetime
on race in this country a lot of people
aren't willing to admit that
but when i was a kid and a black person
came on television
and
they were in a non-servile role this was
a big deal you called everybody in come
and see this
now you have black admirals and generals
and ceos of fortune 500 companies and
heads of foundations
uh university presidents including ivy
league we've elected a black president
twice black vice president
you know to say that we have made
progress is absolutely ridiculous
doesn't mean we reach nirvana
and we still need to continue to make
progress but we've made a lot of
progress and we should we should
decide that we're going to build our
future
on the progress
and not on the things that were
embarrassing about our country
that's powerful what you just said um
um
you know i i can't say that i relate to
that because i'm not a black man
but uh you know being middle eastern
coming up here and you know going out
there in the insurance business while 9
11 happened i got started the day before
9 11 the worst time
for a middle eastern man from iran to
get into financial industry and uh
some people use this as an excuse and
it's not going to help us sell to the
white man or the black man or the asian
man i said nah it's it's it's the
argument if you got a good case if
you're good at what you do if you can
take care of the client exactly you'll
be able to win at the highest level i've
really enjoyed being with having you
have on on the podcast i want to make
one thing very clear dwyane wade it's
arrogant to say you guys created the
first big three first of all kareem
magic james worthy we can go mikhail
parish
bird we can do rodman you know duma
there's so many different things for
them to say even the celtics were the
first big three before they did but the
way it was done i'm gonna take my
talents to south yeah beach that's
probably the biggest you know i'm a
miami guy i'm the biggest dwyane wade
fan ever i can tell you without a doubt
shadow of a doubt it had nothing to do
with race it was the fact that lebron's
decision yeah that's what okay that's
what it was guys
okay whether they got chris bosh or dirk
nowitzki it was not a black or white
thing dirk and whiskey is a white
basketball player so little of the stuff
uh has to do with race right and you
know there's a chapter in my book called
is it racism or classism we do have a
problem with classism
but uh
you know a lot of people who have a lot
of money they only want to deal with
people who have a lot of money they
don't want to deal with other people and
you know why
because people are always asking
no question about it
couple things number one let's put the
link below to the book created equal the
painful past the confusing present and
the hopeful
future of race in america is dr ben
carson's latest book i highly recommend
you get it if you haven't read that i
read america the beautiful years ago if
you haven't seen gifted hands go watch
it as well but i do want to drive it
another thing that you've been working
on is a little patriots learning a
platform for parents grandparents
teachers and caregivers to have a free
online resource to use to teach children
civic lessons history american values at
home in the car or at school
once again check out little patriots new
cartoon series star spangled adventures
click on the link below in the
description we're going to put in the
chat box and it's free as well as a
description and it's free absolutely
it's free uh
really really really enjoyed having you
on thank you so much for coming back
here and when you do decide to run we'll
have you back on
gotta get that little plug in right
there
folks if you enjoyed it as much as we
did give it a thumbs up and subscribe to
the channel and go
uh purchase his latest book and get your
kids on their latest uh website that
they have that's teaching the following
topics that we talked about once again
thanks so much for coming out thank you
take care everybody bye bye bye bye
you